you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
welcome friends to amazing facts Bible
answers live would you like to hear an
amazing fact well there's a young man
named Jack true story he saw a young
lady at work may marry my greatly
attracted his attention but he was too
shy to speak to her so he went to a
local florist and he ordered one red
rose to be sent to her without any
carding closed and everyday he repeated
the order well after four days of
receiving one red rose every day the
young lady's curiosity got the best of
her and she went to the florist and said
who is sending the roses the florist
told her that it was some guy named Jack
who evidently worked where she did yes
she said I think I know who he is
so she searched out Jack and said what's
up with the daily roses he told her he
wanted to ask her out but he was afraid
she accepted his invitation and other
dates followed that one but still
everyday she continued to receive one
red rose then Jack and Mary got engaged
Mary figured the red roses would stop
but still they came finally they were
married in 1927 and even on the
honeymoon she continued to receive one
red rose every day but once the
honeymoon was over that she figured
would be the end of the roses but month
after month even year after year for 47
years of married life every day without
fail she received a red rose finally
Jack died but the very next day there
came another red rose thinking maybe the
florist had not somehow heard the sad
news she called to tell them that Jack
had died and they could stop sending the
roses now but he answered ma'am you
don't seem to understand before
husband died he made arrangements in his
will you'll proceed be receiving one red
rose every day for the rest of your life
which was nine more years and oh yes you
probably know jack better as a Jack
Benny and his wife was Mary Livingston
you know the Bible says in the last days
that the love of many will grow cold but
does that mean it's not possible to have
a loving marriage stay with his friends
were going to learn more on this edition
the Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 phone call
here it is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven one more time
that's 800 God says or 800 four six
three seven 297 calling now is a good
idea we got lines wide open want to
welcome our friends who are not only
listening but watching on Facebook this
program is streaming visually on the
amazing facts Facebook page as well as a
Doug Batchelor Facebook page and my name
is Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross
good even listening frames and pastor
Doug as you always do let's stop the
word of Prayer dear father in heaven to
thank you once again for the opportunity
to open up your word and study together
we do pray that the Holy Spirit we got
our minds our hearts be with those who
are listening Lord lead us into a
clearer understanding of the Bible in
Jesus name Amen amen
pastor you opened the program by just
describing a love story that went on and
on and on throughout this couple's
entire marriage every day she would
receive a red rose a token of her
husband's love for her and of course
that extended even after he passed away
he made arrangements so that they would
be sufficient funds that she would
continue to get a red rose for the rest
of her life yeah it's like that verse
says in 1st Corinthians 13
love never fails and he wanted to make
sure that Mary knew his love would never
fail even though he was gone she would
not forget that she was loved and of
course God wants us to know that his
love for us never fails
there's that popular verse there in
Romans chapter 8 where you can read in
verse 38 and 39 Paul says for I'm
persuaded that neither death or life or
Angels or principalities or powers or
things present or things to come or
height or depth or any other created
thing shall be able to separate us from
the love of God that is in Christ Jesus
our Lord
but jesus said in the last day he's in
Matthew chapter 24 that the love of many
would grow cold and we can see by the
epidemic of failed marriages and
divorces I think they say somewhere
around 45% of all marriages fail the
statistics have actually improved in a
few years not because marriages are
doing better but because as a result of
people living together not even getting
married it looks like more marriages are
succeeding but a lot of people are
forfeiting marriage and folks might be
wondering in this day and age with all
the stress and distractions is it
possible to have a warm loving marriage
relationship and we have a special offer
on that that I think would encourage
people from the Word of God if anyone
would like to receive a study guide
dealing with the subject of marriage
it's called keys for a happy marriage
keys for a happy marriage and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks all you'll have to do is call
our resource phone line that number is
885 six seven four seven and again you
can ask for the study guide called keys
for a happy marriage happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks if you outside
of North American you listening are we
on Facebook so we have listeners all
around literally around the world part
of our international Bible study with
Bible answers live you can also read
that study guide for free at the amazing
facts website just amazing facts dot
o-r-g or amazing facts com click on the
little tab that says Bible study and
you'll be able to get a free copy of
that list and called keys for a happy
marriage
all right well in just a moment here
we're gonna go to the phones and want to
be able to take your Bible questions
again you know we just had a computer
crash here and we you know what those of
you who are watching on Facebook you'll
see what we're talking about right now
all our information comes up to us on
the screen to tell us how many calls are
lined up and who's going to call in and
the screen just went to a screen saver
it's a beautiful picture but it's not
going to help us it's not gonna help us
answer any of the questions here but I
think they're getting that there they go
okay we got several lining up thank you
very much all right all right past
attack we're gonna go to our first
caller and hopefully not really just yet
this forgetting it all put together yeah
it turned off again here so we'll be
able to get our callers in just a moment
this shouldn't affect those who are
actually called in and waiting and we're
just getting the calls up on the screen
I think we're just about ready
we have Ulysses listening from Queens
New York
Ulysses welcome to the program oh good
thanks for calling your question so my
question was was there anyone else
besides Adam and Eve in the garden or
maybe only two individuals in the garden
at that time before they fell well of
course God walked with him in the garden
the Bible tells us in Genesis chapter 2
but you know there were no other people
besides Adam and Eve until they were
chased out of the garden and they
finally they started having children is
that what you're wondering er yeah it's
more it's more along that line me and my
wife what happened Bible studies that we
were just trying to get a better
understanding of how come things only
ever the whole world was populated
through Adam and Eve are you wondering
where did Cain get his wife no I guess
Moo's we were wondering why did they
start having children before they were
kicked out or was there a reason why
they didn't start having children the
last survey like why was yeah great
question
the real question then is partly how
long were they in the garden because
right after the Lord makes Adam and Eve
he says be fruitful
multiply and you know you would
naturally assume God made him perfect
they were perfectly fertile but they
hadn't had any children yet and that's
probably because Eve and Adam were
tempted by the devil very shortly after
creation because they hadn't even had
time to start their family I think the
devil caught them whether were new and
innocent and they were evicted from the
garden after sin and they started having
Cain and Abel and Seth so forth after
they left the Garden of Eden so we don't
know how long but I'm guessing that it
was less than a year after the creation
before they fell okay thank you so much
that answers our question alrighty thank
you good question appreciate it
our next caller that we have is Kendall
listening from Huntsville Alabama
Kendall welcome to the program hey
thanks for having my call and your
question yes
specifically in Revelation 5 8 and 9 it
talks about the 24 elders but it also
talks about the four beasts and I was
wondering if those were literal beasts
or if they were to represent something
well good question
you know let's answer that question with
a question I do that because Jesus often
did it do we see there are other beasts
in Revelation like this woman sitting on
a dragon with seven heads and ten horns
well that dragon is obviously a symbol
and in Revelation you get a lamb which
is technically a beast it's got seven
eyes and seven horns and and it's slain
well there's probably no dead lambs
bleeding in heaven with seven eyes
that's a symbol for Jesus the Lamb of
God and so these creatures around the
throne of God that not only appear there
in Revelation is at four and five they
appear in Ezekiel chapter one same
creatures and this is believed to be a
symbol for the different attributes of
God I think one is a lion an eagle a
calf and a man and this is showing the
the majesty of the Lord and as John's
also got an another perspective that I
get that you I got the majesty is
Matthew Mark is the eagle he's a symbol
for the
and the Luke shows the humanity he's the
doctor and John shows Jesus has the
sacrifice and that's the calf
yeah we've also seen it you can also see
some parallels between the different
phases of Christ's ministry the line is
often associated with royalty and some
scholars see that as being Christ prior
to the Incarnation he was one with the
father he was ruling the universe an ox
which is the second creature around the
throne is a beast of burden it was also
used in sacrifice so Jesus came to this
earth to bear our sins and to die in our
place
the next is a beast that is the face of
a man and folks have seen in that Jesus
our high priest ministering for us in
the heavenly sanctuary and then the
Eagle is the fourth often associated
with speed and judgment and some see in
that when Jesus comes again he comes as
king of kings and Lord of lords
executing judgment upon the weekend and
also redeeming and saving his people so
in the fall of increas they see four
phases of Christ's ministry in man's
salvation oh wow thank you that that
makes a lot more sense now very good
here we appreciate your question and you
know I wish we had a book we probably
ought to write a book on that we get
that question a lot that's a good
subject thank you so much Kindle yep
thank you god bless
next caller that we have is Linda
listening from Middletown Connecticut
Linda welcome to the program
hi hey you know there's also a
Middletown California
I know that and so your question um what
a difference between the house of Judah
and the house of Israel they're both
Jewish aren't they not technically oh
let me see if I can explain Israel
included all 12 of the tribes Judah that
was mostly the southern kingdom that
were from there the Jews the word Jew
comes from the tribe of Judah it's sort
of a corruption of the word from Judah
there was a civil war back after the
time of King Solomon and the tribe of
Judah along with Benjamin and most of
the priests which were the Levites they
separated from the Northern Kingdom that
was called the ten
and they were called the Israel they
Israel was a term that meant the rest of
the tribes often the ten tribes were
ultimately carried off by the Assyrians
years later hundreds of years after the
Civil War and then finally the children
of Judah were carried to Babylon after a
war the children of Judah came back to
the Land of Israel most of the ten
tribes did not come back they
intermarried with the Assyrians many of
them sort of disappeared
a lot of the Semitic people have some
Jewish blood because of the ten tribes
that were scattered through Assyria
there is a difference between the house
of Israel was the Northern Kingdom the
house of Judah was the southern kingdom
David was from the southern kingdom he
was a Jew from the the tribe of Judah
okay that's a long answer but hopefully
that made some sense
yeah have you ever wrote any books on
this you know we do have a book we can
send you that talks about spiritual
Israel and we'll be happy to send you a
free copy of that if you just call the
resource line the number to call is 800
eight three five six seven four seven
and you can again just ask for the book
called spiritual Israel we'll be happy
to send that out to anyone who calls and
asks makes fun of that we have is Lewis
listing Connecticut Lewis welcome to the
program Oh Louis I think it is it is
such an honor to talk with both of you
thank you for taking my cue
hi my question is this my wife and I
were interested in finding an activity
to do together and so I would like to
propose to her ballroom dancing or wall
C and I'm interested in finding out the
Bible prohibit dancing with your wife
well the bible does talk about dancing
typically in the bible you'll see that
they would dance in celebration but the
women would go out and dance with the
women David went and danced before the
Lord and if you've ever been to a Jewish
wedding I want a more orthodox jewish
wedding you could even look at them
online you'll see the women take hands
and they'd kind of dance on one circle
no men take hands they dance in another
circle and the
kind of saw it as maybe being immodest
for the men and women to start dancing
together that doesn't mean that a
husband I mean you know if anyone if
there ever is a case when a man and
woman could dance together it would be a
marriage I don't know that you do it
publicly but a lot of let's face it a
lot of the co-ed dancing that happens in
our culture is extremely sexually
suggestive now I know that the barn
dancing in the ballroom dancing would be
the exception to that since since
sometimes it's hard to draw the line
between one on the other and since I
have no rhythm I don't dance I tried to
do a couple of school proms when I was
young and and it was an embarrassment
but in any event you know it'd be great
for you guys to get some exercise
together and there's probably a lot of
things you can do I personally I don't I
don't get too excited about the public
dancing but I'm probably just an old
fogey but you do have you typically you
have examples in the Bible Miriam led
the women in dances when they were
victory victories over the Egyptians
you've got the women that came out
dancing when David and Saul defeated the
Philistines one bad dance is you got
salomi who danced for Herod when John
the Baptist got beheaded remember she
asked for the head of John the Baptist
on a silver platters and that was
probably a sexually suggestive dance so
I'll give you half my kingdom if you'll
come dance for me so that was a thing a
little different a waltz that wasn't a
little know necessarily sexually
explicit right no I agree yeah they did
the waltzes and some of the marches and
you know they've got some of these
square dances yeah you got to listen
real carefully it's almost like a
mathematical operation but yeah I won't
condemn a person for that I just I
usually advise against the borders there
hey well god bless you I appreciate your
question thank you all right bye-bye
bye-bye my next caller that we have is
earnest listening from Virginia earnest
welcome to the program hey doctor hey
how are you doing good thank you for
darling yes and I read only have a
question I have a stay just some again I
get have to ask you I'm trying to figure
out the best way to say this I think yes
and I think a lot of PS a lot of there's
a lot of debate on you know anyway I'm
trying I'm gonna try to say the best way
I can about do you know why Jesus is
called the spirit of prophecy you know
there is a well first of all Christ is
the word right and the Bible often talks
about the spirit of prophecy being
connected with the word right if you
read in if you look for instance in the
I think it's Isaiah 8:20
it says bind the testimony seal the law
among my disciples now notice the word
testimony law then you jump to
Revelation chapter 12 and the last verse
is verse 17 in Revelation 12 and it says
the dragon is wroth with the woman and
he goes to make war with the remnant of
her seed that keep the commandments of
God that's the law and the testimony of
Jesus now what does the testimony of
Jesus you go to Revelation 19 verse 10
you there you've got it the testimony of
Jesus is spirit of prophecy so the law
and the prophets they are the Word of
God in Christ of course he is the word
that became flesh okay yeah right let's
see this what I'm saying
see I understand the spirit of prophecy
but a lot of people date they see a lot
of people don't understand why Jesus was
called a spirit of prophecy because you
know the Spirit of God himself that
spirit alone from the beginning that
created all things I see a lot of people
think that the Spirit of God was three
persons but the Spirit of God alone
demonstrated his power and three
different it demonstrated as power in
three different time periods well do you
do you believe that the Father Son and
Holy Spirit are all the same person
yeah it's not a person it's just that
one spirit see one because when in a new
and the new test in the old testament it
was justice for he was in spirit form
Jesus was in spirit form when the
fullness of time came when he came into
the new testament when he conceived in
the womb
now did Jesus you have God conceived the
Holy Spirit through Mary but Christ and
the Holy Spirit are separate entities
and persons in the Godhead you know
that's why Jesus said to baptize in the
name of the Father the Son and the whole
no no okay I want it I want to say is
yet they were separate that that's why
if you think about this as they were
separate the scripture would tell you
just like in in Galatians 3 and 20 it
says it's a mediator is not a mediator
of one but God is one
now see if you if you take away from one
is 0 if you add to one is more than one
see God is one no I I think there's a
problem there I'd respectfully disagree
I think there's a problem there with
your analogy in that you're assuming
that one is always numerical quantity
when God says hear o Israel the Lord our
God is one Deuteronomy chapter 6 he's
not saying there's only one person he's
saying God is one and United Jesus said
in John 17 father I pray that the
Apostles can be one as you and I are one
God said let us make man in our image
jesus said a man and woman get married
and they become one flesh but the two
separate persons God the Father Son and
spirit are one in being perfectly United
like you'd have one family but they're
three distinct persons you know
something else interesting about that
there are actually two different words
used in the original Hebrew which of
course the Old Testament was written in
that's translated in English as one
there is a plural form of the word one
meaning unity and purpose so you could
have more than just one numerical entity
and then there is another word we
simply means one as we think of it today
in numerical value so to the Jewish mind
the idea of being one was more than just
new miracle but it was one in purpose
and unity and you know we have a free
book we'll be happy to send you Ernest
we probably got to move on to another
caller and it's called the Trinity a
matter of fact I just wrote I wrote a
little book on the Trinity but I'll send
you the full book on the Trinity that I
just wrote and it's called the Trinity
one God or three and we'll send your
free copy the number to cold-eeze 808
three five six seven four seven you can
ask for the book on the Trinity what
happy to send that out to you Ernest or
anybody who calls and asks Michael is
listening from Michigan Michael welcome
to the program hey doing great thank you
for calling in your question yes I hope
oh yeah I have a question I have an
apartment here and a lot of people have
asked me how can you prove that God
exists without using your Bible and not
best so many people about this I got
different answers and you know so many
different good answers I by the way but
I just wanted to give you all right now
Michael and we're gonna bring your
volume down a little bit cuz we hear the
radio in the background but I first
think I want to say is I did a sermon Oh
probably five six months ago and it's
called can you prove the existence of
God and I specifically came from I used
to be an agnostic or atheist I came from
the perspective of someone who doesn't
believe the Bible and I thought is there
other evidence for God so I hope you'll
go online and look you can just type in
Doug Batchelor on YouTube
existence of God it'll probably pop up
but let me give you some quick answers
one is that you do not have organization
and interworking systems without some
outside intelligence and a designer it's
just as simple as realizing that if
you're walking across the desert and you
see a motorcycle on a kickstand you
would never ever believe that that
motorcycle with all its intricate design
and function used up out of the rocks no
matter how many billions of years went
by there was an outside intelligent
engineer that developed that and a human
a mouse is infinitely more complex than
a motorcycle and so the idea that you
get organization and design and even the
symbiotic relationships between a
hummingbird and a flower are bees and
flowers that would never evolve
spontaneously that one cannot exist
without the other
and there has to be an intelligence that
designed these things and why do you
have beauty why do we even acknowledge
beauty that you know there's a lord that
loves the beautiful we're made in the
image of God we have a lot of the same
characteristics of God so I think
there's a lot of evidence you got some
ideas oh yeah there's one of them that I
thought was pretty compelling as people
study the cell they discovered the the
the DNA inside the nucleus of the cell
it's been just all that information
about the cell dividing comes from the
DNA but of course DNA can't exist
without a cell without the nucleus so
the question often arises if the cells
somehow evolved by itself it wouldn't be
able to multiply itself without the DNA
and the DNA wouldn't be able to exist
without a cell which came first so all
of them came instantaneously God created
it and put it together I'm putting you
back on Michael to that that makes some
sense yeah well that's just the tip of
the iceberg oh there's a lot of good
evidence out there in in science in
nature that and even in philosophy that
proves the existence of God
but you know take a look go online and
try and take a look for that sermon that
I mentioned we don't really have oh we
do have a book called wonders of
creation mm-hmm that oh wait what about
the book we got a book called when
science flunk how we do when evolution
flunked the science do you know we don't
name that out too often but it's a great
little book and it's simply called when
evolution flunked the science test and
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks free that number is
we do still have some lines open if you
want to call in with your Bible question
we still got the other half of the
program that's coming up and that's 800
4 6 3 7 2 9 7 I don't think I've told
you our website yet this whole program
it's real simple amazing facts dot o-r-g
you can listen to these programs and
find much more be right back
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts when Susan's and
Michael's whirlwind relationship led to
a wedding they had no idea how hard
married life could be before they knew
it they were on the stormy path towards
divorce but that's when God led them to
an amazing fax broadcast and there they
saw the biblical view of marriage as
presented in knowing Jesus finally they
understood what it meant to love
sacrificially like Christ and today
Susan and Michael are joyfully married
sharing what they learned with others
now you friend have an opportunity to
help someone today and to make an
eternal difference for more people like
Michael and Susan you're a simple
investment of faith and amazing facts
we'll keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that you've
learned and it's easy to make a donation
just visit give dot amazing facts to RG
or send your gift to p o-- box
10:58 Roseville California 9 5 6 7 8 you
can also give us a call at 877 five zero
six one seven five one the number again
eight seven seven five zero six one
seven five one thank you for tuning in
to Bible answers live and don't forget
to share with others the amazing Bible
facts you have learned here today want
to know God's plan for our world and
solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more prefer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
com or by calling 858 seven two seven
five
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evenings
program call 888-814-3923 years has left
and wants a divorce and we're both
believers I don't know what to do I
don't know what I'm going to church I'm
going to church I'm I'm in a good group
of people but I don't know what what the
Bible says about with what's going on
right now and I just I'm trying to stand
in in the gap and wait for her but I
don't know if you have any advice I've
listened to you guys for years and
respect whatever you say so I would
really appreciate your advice all right
well first of all that's a very
difficult thing and we'll be keeping you
in prayer hey I wrote a book called
marriage divorce and remarriage and of
course when people read the book I'm
hoping that they can salvage and restore
their marriages and you know Jesus said
what God has joined together let not man
put asunder
marriage is to be a covenant that should
be as it says till death do you part
Paul said that it's only through death
and it's a covenant supposed to last and
it's we they become one flesh now I hope
you have people that you can talk to you
there that can give you some good
biblical counsel we do have the lesson
that we offer tonight which is called
the keys to a happy marriage there are
some tips in there in case there are
some bumpy spots in your relationship
that you can do first thing I'd say is
completely surrender yourself to the
Lord because God can work miracles but
he does them best when we are fully
consecrated make yourself as attractive
as possible now what I mean by that I've
seen sometimes when one spouse leaves
the other they start to hound the other
person and they make things even worse
by you know just in every time they pick
up the phone they're begging them to
come back or whatever and you know I
think the you want to make yourself
respect that person's freedom make
yourself as attractive as you can by
being kind by being listening by being
prayerful doing everything you can to be
supportive you don't ever want to be
vindictive because you're hurt you don't
want to hurt back that's the reaction a
lot of people are so wounded because of
an imminent divorce they start lashing
out as soon as you get lawyers involved
and then things start to go downhill
because the lawyers don't make money
typically very few lawyers have the
integrity to say I don't want to offer
you my services because I want you to
save your marriage they make money when
you litigate and so I always say try to
get a pastor involved and not a lawyer
and do some counseling but you know
that's probably the best we could do
right now in the short time we have and
we'll send you that book he's the happy
marriage and the other book is called
marriage divorce and remarriage and
we'll be praying for you as well Jason
please do I deeply appreciate thank you
for being who you are you're a great
tool well bless your heart and and we'll
hold yet before the Lord the number to
call to receive that free book is called
marriage divorce and remarriage and the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
to send the CJC anyone who calls and
asks 883 five six seven four seven he
can ask for the book called marriage
divorce and remarriage you can also ask
for the study guide called keys to happy
marriage and we'll be sending that out
to anyone who gives us a call next
qualies James listening in Maryland
James welcome to the program hey good
evening thank you for taking my call
absolutely I have a question regarding
Adam and Eve when the Bible talks about
them eating from the forbidden fruit was
that literal well it's pretty clear in
the context when it says God placed all
different kinds of trees in the garden
that were good for food and he goes
right from talking about very practical
things we would agree with being literal
that he had foods and the fruits had
nuts and there were nuts and seeds and
fruit to eat and and then God says and
in the middle of the garden he placed a
tree of life and a tree of the knowledge
of good and evil after Adam and Eve
sinned God said they're evicted from the
garden lest they eat from the tree of
life and live forever in other words God
didn't want them to physically reach out
and eat this fruit that had some enzyme
we're evidently missing now they keep
cells from deteriorating over time and
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil I believe they were real trees and
there was real fruit now probably when
Adam and Eve eat the forbidden fruit God
really put a test there to test the
loyalty or he allowed it but it must
have been some real kind of fruit tree
that got allowed to be there I don't
think it was just a spiritual tree most
scholars take it that way but yeah
appreciate that good practical question
thank you hope that helped James next
photo that we have is Jesse listening
from Vancouver JC welcome to the program
hi thank you thank you for calling are
you still there yes yes I had a question
on Matthew 18 verse 18 and 19 all right
you want us to read that and then we'll
do our best to answer it first sure that
would be fantastic
all right do you have that what do you
do it says assuredly I sound to you
these are the words of Jesus whatever
you bind on earth will be bound in
heaven whatever you loose on earth
we'll be loosed in heaven again I say to
you if two of you agree on earth
concerning anything that you ask it will
be done for them by My Father in heaven
yeah no are you wondering what does that
mean well yeah it confuses me more than
19 but both of them confused me so I
just thought you guys probably had a
good answer well first of all things
that are done here in this world do
impact what happens in eternity
so when went through our prayers and our
intercession
you know we pray and ask for things for
God to intervene those prayers are he
responds in heaven so when he talks
about binding and loosing we actually
people are bound and loosed by our
proclaiming the gospel people who are
bound by sin when you preach to them
they're freed when we fail to intercede
for them or fail to preach the gospel to
them they remount remain bound now God
is not saying we're gonna pray and say
hey I think I'll bind that person over
there or I'll loose that person over
there but there was one time when Paul
prayed there was this sorcerer that was
trying to turn away Sergius Paulus and
Paul kind of pronounced the whammy on
him and he was struck blind because he
was working for the devil
so God answers prayers of those on earth
that influence other people's destiny
it's kind of a big picture you get
anything yeah absolutely he's also
talking about Jesus with referencing the
church and he's giving the Church
authority in the preaching of the gospel
and in preaching the gospel as pastor
Doug says just like Jesus came to set
the captives free those were held
captive by sin so those who preach the
gospel through the preaching of the word
people respond to that word there are
other being set free from sin or their
hardening their heart against God and
setting themselves in sand they're
binding themselves in sin so the
principle there is Jesus was giving the
apostles the privilege to do the work
that Jesus did on the earth that of
preaching the gospel and making a
difference in people's
for eternity yeah and also this verse
comes on the heels of Jesus giving the
church some authority to reprimand
people that wouldn't forgive each other
and they could even be put out of the
church which Paul talks about in 1st
Corinthians I think it's 7
but anyway does that help a little bit
yeah totally I I I was just I had no
idea that it was about prayer and stuff
like that so I was I was definitely just
confused because I was like is it
talking about marriage like oh yeah well
good I'm glad that helps a little bit we
really appreciate your calling Jesse you
would like via the lesson we've got
called keys to a happy marriage and I'm
gonna call his 808 three five six seven
four seven just asked for the study
guide our free offer tonight keys for a
happy marriage
next quality we have is James listening
from Atlanta Georgia James welcome to
the program hey I really appreciate
y'all taking my call yeah so recently
I've gotten diagnosed with tinnitus like
a really high pitch ringing in the ears
mm-hmm and it's kind of been an
unfortunate like a like a backdrop or a
soundtrack to all my waking hours and
this is not a science doesn't really
know a lot about it and they think
there's no cure for it that they know of
and I didn't know this is this is really
challenging my faith on a on a strong
level and and and I believe what I
believe in all the scriptures you know
to me like I'm not thorough with it but
um I just didn't know if either one of
you gentlemen have ever prayed for
somebody a seeing somebody else prayed
for and actually seeing like like a real
manifestation of healing like a like a
permanent healing that took place it
sides couldn't explain or anything like
that yeah a matter of fact it's
interesting you would ask that because
just immediately before the program
Pastor Ross and I had an appointment we
stopped and we had prayer and an
anointing for an individual that had a
serious medical problem and we do
believe in miracles we do believe in
healing you know pastor Ross and I
I'm just thinking of something that we
were in on together so to speak one the
sister we know of that had liver cancer
it was very serious and her everyone
could see her health failing we prayed
and had an anointing service and and she
then did have a procedure and the doctor
said that the the tumor was
non-malignant and she was healed and
she's a perfectly healthy young mother
right now
so that was dramatic I've been at the
hospital bed not exaggerating where a
person was on a ventilator
the folks kind of came in too you know
so I could have prayer and and I didn't
even think God would answer my prayer to
be perfectly honest but they kind of
asked me if I'd pray for their mother
and she had a stroke and looked like
that she was brain dead and and so I
prayed and left a little while later
they called said have you heard mom
opened her eyes and sat up and said she
was hungry this happened about five
years ago and she was in church last
week still I'm just dramatic healing as
so I do believe in healing and now I'll
tell you something else just to keep
perspective I have tinnitus what you're
talking about
and it's a constant high pitch ringing
in my ears now it's in one ear in
particular and you know it it's
something that often happens is you get
older it can be associated with if
you've worked with loud noises which I
did you can damage there are very fine
hairlike elements inside there the
cochlear part of your ear it's they're
microscopic and they can get damaged and
they could send out false signals where
just comes back to us like a high pitch
and they can be very annoying and you'll
notice sometimes if you have stress it
gets a little louder and sometimes if
you're relaxed it may get a little
softer when you wake up in the morning
but God can heal I know people that have
been healed of it he hasn't healed me
yet but hey I sometimes if you're not
healed you say Lord
that's what Paul said give me grace your
strength is made perfect in weakness
like I've wondered if this is if this is
how I want say just calling you don't
mean but like if this is lot for me do
you mind my asking I'm not a doctor but
how old are you I'm 41 yeah you're still
pretty young were you in the military no
sir but I've done them as a firefighter
for a number of years worked at a
airport for a number
the line around oil out yes sir
yeah that's that's often that's it's a
trigger there well you know brother why
don't we appear for you right now people
who are joining us on the air they can
do that and and we'll put this in God's
hands father in heaven we just want to
lift up in prayer James and I know
others listening may have some medical
issues and they're wondering if you'd be
willing to heal lord I pray that you'll
just show that you are God that heals
that you'll work out your will in their
lives and Lord if for some reason that
healing doesn't come until the
Resurrection Day I pray that you just
give us grace to be faithful in spite of
our trials so be with James Lord and I
pray that you work in his life and
reveal your power in Jesus name Amen
amen
all right thanks you're Col James I'm
just thinking we've got we do have a
study guide called God's free health
plan talks about health principles that
sometimes reverse medical problems
absolutely the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven that is our resource phone line
you can ask for this study guide called
God's free health plan again that's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven Amanda or Armando is
listening from New York hey Amanda hi
how you doing good and your question
tonight hey thank you for taking my call
I appreciate that thank you absolutely
okay my question is you know according
to the Genesis chapter our for sat on 17
I don't and Eve had two sons
so Cain killed Abel and ran away from
the pressing up below all right yes yes
so the Bible is talking about he found a
woman and created a new problem yes so
I'm very passive weird these people came
from because according to the Bible
there was nothing but K Abel all right
you got a Bible in front of you yes I do
if you go to Genesis chapter 5 you can
read in verse Genesis 5 verse 4 says
after he begat Seth all the days of Adam
or eight hundred years
and he had sons and daughters Adam and
Eve had many other sons and daughters
besides Cain Abel and Seth and in the
very beginning came no doubt married one
of his sisters and if you read your
Bible you'll also find out that Abraham
married his half-sister Sarah
Jacob married his first cousin as Isaac
married a first cousin so in the early
days it was not unusual for a brother to
marry sister there were no genetic
problems in the beginning man's blood
was perfect back then Cain took one of
his sisters Adam and Eve had many
children they lived hundreds of years
and there was nothing wrong with it back
then so that's who we marry good
question or rondo thank you you're
listening to Bible answers live this
broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 885 six seven four seven once again
that's 800 eight three five six seven
four seven next we have is Bill
listening from Illinois bill welcome to
the program hi thanks for taking my call
my question is this what do you what is
your understanding about I don't know if
you call this a doctrine or not but I
say that the doctrine of eternal
security also called I've heard one
saved always saved yes yeah that's
probably one of the most hotly debated
subjects among Protestants and even
between Protestants and Catholics
you know the whole Church of England I'm
reading a book right now they were split
over this issue for years between the
Puritans and the Church of England
Calvin is the one who sort of really
refined that teaching the idea that once
you're saved you can't really be lost
it's he believed that God has
predetermined who will be saved and we
really don't have a choice it's called
the sovereignty of God and that if we're
saved it's because God calls us to
salvation and others are not saved but I
don't believe the Bible says that yeah
I'm not I'm not I'm sorry I'm not
interested in predestination
all I want to know is do you think a
person can lose their salvation if
they've ever been truly saved well let's
look at the Bible you have you have an
example of somebody like King Saul who
was called by God filled with a spirit
and God did wonderful things through him
but Saul began to cling to pride talking
about the New Testament
under Jesus Christ our Lord and Savior
who were people saved under in the Old
Testament I don't know and I'm not
particularly interested in the Old
Testament I'm interested in the New
Covenant and well everyone who saved is
saved by Jesus I just wanted I wondered
if you thought that the people in the
Old Testament were saved by some other
method that nobody saved by works we're
all saved by grace Jesus said Abraham
longed to see my day and he saw it and
so they were saved by faith in Christ
they were saved looking forward in faith
were saved by looking back into faith
but so alright I gave you an Old
Testament example let me give you a New
Testament example you've got the example
of Paul said that demas has forsaken me
so here is someone who was a follower
who got discouraged Peter talks about
someone who was washed who returns to
their vomit or wallowing in the mire a
Hebrews chapter 4 talks about somebody
that has the Holy Spirit and they turn
away it's nearly impossible to renew
them to repentance and in Revelation
you've got an example blocked him out of
my book God did yeah and he says he says
to the church I'll take your candlestick
out of your place unless you repent I
mean you have Paul in 1st Corinthians
9:27 it says but I discipline my body
and bring it into subjection lest when I
have preached to others i myself should
become disqualified or a castaway so
Paul recognized that he could lose his
salvation and that's why I had to keep
that connection with God and then you
have Judas who was out preaching with
the other apostles that grieved away the
Holy Spirit yeah performing miracles him
well what about John 3:16 whoever
believes in Him will not perish but have
everlasting life absolutely yeah
yeah everlasting life and what is it
what does believe mean does that mean
just believe one time or does that mean
an ongoing faith well it means an
ongoing faith yeah so as long as a
person has an ongoing faith they are
saved yeah I don't I just don't see
anybody who's lost their salvation in
the New Testament there's warnings about
it
Judas never was a believer he held the
bag I mean it's pretty clear he didn't
he didn't believe in Jesus and by the
way Jesus had yet to be crucified at
that point so are there people when when
that way you don't believe the Old
Testament where as an example so I can't
use the example of David who prayed take
not thy Holy Spirit from me but I see
well well well you can you said he
prayed that God not do that and God
didn't do it right but what if he hadn't
prayed it well he'll never know will we
so as we're not presented we're not
presented with a hypothetical there yeah
now one of the challenges that you have
with the one saved teaching is it
whenever we say somebody who you point
to like Judas and you say well they
never really were saved
so people walking around today and even
in Christ's time how does a person know
if they are one of those who are really
saved or just think they're saved I'm
not quite sure what you're asking I'm
saying that how do you know who's really
someone who's really saved
I'm sure thinks they're saved or you do
you think there's anybody that thinks
are saved and isn't why would they even
think they work they won't well let me
quote the words of Jesus he says and he
says in Matthew 24 no actually it's in
Matthew 7 many will come to me in that
day saying Lord Lord we've taught in
your streets we've done many wonderful
works and he'll say I don't know you
they think they're saved and they he
says depart from me you who are using
their work there they're using their
work well I'm just telling you they
thought they were saved and you said
that you think a person who thinks are
saved to say yes
okay but your example I don't think is
is appropriate because we're saved by
grace through faith not of words so you
think once a person saved there's
nothing they can do to be lost I I
really find it difficult to conceive of
because John 3:16 says quite clearly
well a saved person let's so if someone
comes to the altar when they're in 10
years old they accept Jesus and they
pray the prayer and they say hey the
pastor says you're saved and they follow
the Lord but then in their 20s they go
to college and they just go wild and you
know I won't catalog the sins but they
turn from God is that person saved while
they're living in the world um
there's every indication in people that
I know personally who behaved in the way
that you just described who later come
back to Jesus and were never really lost
well I agree if they come back just like
Peter repented and he returned to the
Lord he'll save him but when they're
abounding in love they never they they
never really were lost the Holy Spirit
cling them around
okay you know well this is why I said at
the beginning of your question this is a
subject that has been debated for
centuries can I send you a book that's
got a lot more verses than I can share
in this a little time we've got
it's called can a saved man be lost here
and we'll send you a free copy bill the
number two Coley's 808 three five six
seven four seven and again just asked
for the book called can a saved man be
lost on bababa to send that to anyone
who calls and asks again the number is
883 five six seven four seven my next
caller we have calling from Australia we
have asha calling from australia asha
welcome to the program you're on the air
can you hear us I think I may have
wandered from their phone one more time
asha going once
australia takes a while for a signal to
bounce from australia asha are you there
hello okay okay
hey we got just two minutes left in your
question tonight good evening this is
such a pleasure
to talk to both of you I'll be really
excited you need to turn down your radio
you're gonna be hearing feedback sorry
about that I have my son here he's seven
years old is it okay to pass the phone
to him for his pleasure okay there you
go Nathan
how pasta doesn't pasta sauce my name is
Nathan and I live in Australia I just
wanted to ask you where in the Bible
says but that Satan was rebelling
against the Lord and he was kicked out
of heaven very good question Thank You
Nathan you know I've got a boy named
Nathan - you find that verse in
Revelation chapter 12 and pastor Ross
probably I think it's verse 9 verse
seven begins ok the war in heaven you
want to read that for us yes says there
was war in heaven Michael and his angels
that's the name for Jesus prophetic name
fought with the Dragon that's the devil
and it says verse 8 they did not prevail
nor was a place found for them in heaven
any longer verse 9 says so the Great
Dragon was cast out that old serpent of
old called the devil and Satan yeah and
then there's one other verse that says
that Jesus said I saw Satan like
lightning fall from heaven there was a
war between good and evil and you know
we can send you we have a study guide
that talks about that battle and it's
called did God create a devil Nathan if
you're in Australia you can read that
for free online go to the amazing facts
website that's amazing facts dot o-r-g
and we're always thrilled to get a call
from young people and especially
thrilled when they come all the way from
Australia because I know it's a
different time there bless your hearts
listening friends we're running out of
time we just like to remind you that
there's so much more you can learn about
amazing facts from the Word of God just
go to amazing facts dot o-r-g god
willing we'll study his word together
again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation and even discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love
then what went wrong
[Music]
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit
AF bookstore com
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website
[Music]
you